european leaders arriving in brussels
for a crucial meeting on ukraine
at the start of the crisis they had
surprised many with unity and strong
sanctions
but a sixth package of measures
including an oil ban has been stalled
for nearly a month some expressed
optimism the deadlock can be broken
there is high chances of being passed
through
and
the unity should be maintained in the
european council as we have done up to
now so that's important to continue but
such an upbeat assessment was soon
dashed by the eu leader with the
friendliest relations with vladimir
putin hungary's recently re-elected
prime minister victor orban has for
weeks been the one to oppose the oil ban
to win him over it's now being proposed
that to begin with the ban will only
apply to oil that comes on ships from
russia not supplies that are delivered
by pipeline
but mr orban told reporters there was no
deal yet means you know that we are in a
very difficult situation
basically because of the irresponsible
behavior of the commission
the head of the commission didn't
address such criticism but she did
suggest there wouldn't be a breakthrough
during this meeting we are not there yet
but it has matured for sure
my expectations are low that it will be
solved in the next 48 hours but i'm
confident that thereafter there will be
a possibility the european leaders were
joined by video link from kiev by
president zielenski a show of unity and
solidarity for ukraine but all that is
rather overshadowed by the continuing
impasse on sanctions
james bay's al jazeera brussels
ukraine's foreign minister says keeve is
for state frustrated by the slow pace of
negotiations
you know well how we are tiring ukraine
of some special decisions half measures
special approaches some models which
some european capitals are constantly
inventing for ukraine we need clear
legal confirmation that ukraine is part
of the european integration project and
such confirmation will be giving ukraine
the status of candidates
meanwhile a french journalist has been
killed by russian shelling in ukraine
frederick leclerc
was a reporter with bfm tv
the french foreign minister who is in
ukraine has called investigation into
his killing in luhansk
the french president emmanuel macron
also paid tribute by tweeting the
following federic le clercymoth was in
ukraine to show the reality of the war
he was aboard a humanitarian bus
alongside civilians forced to flee to
escape russian bombs and he was fatally
shot
saying basravi is in kiev he has more on
the circumstances surrounding the french
journalists death
we started hearing reports of a
journalist that had been killed just a
few hours ago and now we can name him uh
french president emmanuel macron has uh
named the gentleman who was
killed earlier today and his name is
frederick leclerc imhoff and the
circumstances of his death are are
tragic it has to be said um he was
accompanying a a rescue effort in the
luhansk region we're not sure exactly
where as yet it hasn't been confirmed
but we are hearing some social media
chatter to suggest that it was
evacuations being carried out from the
city of several donetsk which has been
under siege by russian forces for some
time
during that rescue operation the head of
the luhansk region made a statement
about the incident that happened he says
that the evacuation has been officially
stopped russians fired at a car that was
going to pick up people a french
journalist was killed an armored
evacuation vehicle was picking up 10
people from the area
that came under enemy fire shrapnel and
shells pierced the armored vehicle
that was being used in a fatal wound to
the neck was received by this accredited
french journalist who was covering the
evacuation at the time so certainly a
very tragic incident it brings the death
toll
of journalists
in this conflict since the russian
invasion began to approximately 24 that
is the latest figure we have pales in
comparison it has to be said to the 9
000 estimated civilian deaths that have
taken place some estimates put that
number much higher but it does indicate
how difficult in danger it is to report
this war it's only been going on since
february
let's take a quick look at the state of
playing ukraine's front lines at the
moment the areas in red are controlled
by russia and its separatist allies the
governor of luhan says russian forces
have entered the city of several donetsk
there's also heavy fighting in these
areas as ukrainian troops hold back
russian attempts to encircle forces in
donetsk
it's a different story in the south
where ukraine has managed to launch a
counter-offensive to recapture kessan
we can speak now to hannah celeste
who is a security studies program
director at the foreign policy and
security think tank ukrainian prison she
joins us from odessa in ukraine thank
you for speaking to us on the programme
the focus of the battle as we're hearing
uh in in uh there earlier in is in the
east right now and
the russians appear to be throwing
everything they have at it they do hold
an overwhelming advantage when it comes
to weapons and firepower how long do you
think the ukrainians can hold them off
as things stand
definitely the last week the fightings
intensified significantly on the east
front uh that is mostly in the lugansk
and the nets regions and it is very
difficult to say now uh what will be the
exact time that ukraine can
uh stay like this because we can't say
that russians really advanced in some
territories they advanced more like in
lugansk in some territories they've been
advancing and then thrown back so the
fighting is really just in the meat of
what is happening at the same time this
week and the next week ukraine is
expecting very significant supply of the
heavy weapons that's been already
announced by the united states of
america the last week the 4 billion
supports being signed by the president
and over there we are expecting that
type of the weapons that ukraine really
needs now for the counter fans that's
multi-launch rocket systems that the uh
drones uh the combat drones that ukraine
can use over there and the supply of
this weapons weapons can significantly
change the operative situation
what are you actually hearing about
whether you are going to get these
weapons and when because we've heard
keeve express frustration
uh again and again on on the slow pace
uh of a variety of things for example
the sanction talks uh and and demanding
more weapons do you feel that europe and
the us is addressing your concerns
i would not unite all countries together
because we have really very different
situation uh some countries even like
the united states of america supplying
the weapons very often in 72 hours from
the decision made to the actual being
already in the unit on the ground the
question is that when you supply
javelins it can be done easier than when
you supply the multi-launch rocket
system you just imagine the sizes and
the logistics especially in the times of
war at the same time we definitely have
the problems like with germany when uh
it's been announced more than a month
ago that they're supplying us with the
unnecessary armored verticals and we are
still expecting them on the ground
at the same time lithuania where's tony
is supplying as soon as possible what
they have and even australia the latest
decisions about the uh uh the kyles that
we received from them we received them
literally in four days from
announcements and you can imagine what
are the logistics from australia to
ukraine so i would not say that this
frustration is general against all the
partners it's definitely against the
individual partners and ukraine
understands that we need as soon as
possible everything that's why we are in
such a demanding mood because each day
it means that each day of the suffering
of people on the ground
we're hearing the term
war of attrition being used to describe
russia's strategy in parts of the east
what is your understanding of that term
and what do you think the logic is
behind russia's tactics
definitely you could see it for the last
three months especially in towns like
mariupoli or harkid that russia is
trying just to destroy everything what
is there there are several reasons for
this first of all is to bring fear for
people on the ground so uh the people
would not support any of the military
actions and
those who can oppose on the ground like
guerrillas a partisan they would be just
leaving the territory because they
understand the uh severe actions and
consequences the same is for journalists
journalists are usually not allowed to
be there where they have very heavy
fightings are happening for their
security uh reasons but also because the
russian federation currently um
demonstrated that their armed forces are
not so strong as they promoted them so
on the north they were not able to have
a close fight and they started to use
the last months as much as possible the
long-range missiles that are very
destructive you can imagine the furore
again abroad or others uh what are the
consequences of these missiles and they
also use a lot in eastern ukraine the uh
turmeric missiles and the cluster
missiles so those that most of the
countries even prohibited for the use
especially in the residential areas but
in this way they cannot come even to the
territory of ukraine they can be very
safe at their roman territory but
demolish as much as possible of the
civilian infrastructure
can you tell us a bit more about what is
happening in kerason because we're
hearing that ukraine has launched a
counter offensive there
how how how are they doing in pushing
russia back
first of all it's necessary to
understand that her song region is very
long it's maybe not so big but it is
very long because it is covering uh the
whole territory both in azov and in uh
the blacks here just uh above the crania
so the situation is very different on
the different parts of these uh
frontline however definitely because her
stone been under the occupation since
the beginning of march and it is very
difficult situation in terms of human
rights violations over there russians
already arrested more than 500 people
only in the city of herson where the
demonstration in march and april being
almost daily of the i mean pro-ukrainian
demonstration demonstrations against the
uh russian occupied forces over there so
as for now ukraine is trying to get
village by village road by road a little
bit of territory is coming closer to the
city of herzone to have the possibility
for the counter attack and but also to
minimize the possibilities of the attack
against mikko live city the next one
after his own to the west as for now
it's really step by step very slowly
because the biggest forces are
concentrated on the east kirsten
probably will be the next region
assuming the situation on the east will
stabilize a little bit more
hannah i really appreciate you speaking
to us on al jazeera hannah celeste
security studies and program director at
the ukrainian prison